[Applaus]
es ist natürlich sehr wichtig dass wir
große veränderung schaffen und die große
von apples mac wächter und profit profit
profit sowie zwei fahrzeugen die
finanzielle nachhaltigkeit dieser also
dass das system auf schreiten quasi aber
das hat sich einig so priorität wie der
andere
jessica altenburger will das leben der
slumbewohner von lima verändern ihre
firma vermietet trockentoiletten an die
ärmsten im islam gibt es weder
fließendes wasser noch richtige weg ist
unter solchen bedingungen ist ein leben
in würde nicht möglich doch wie kann
eine toilette an leben verändern
davon handelt dieser füllung
[Applaus]
die unternehmerin begleitet ihre
angestellten bei der wöchentlichen wc
abfuhr
und wie geht das
das ist jetzt eine verbotene wörter muss
zuerst muttertag sie
da bringe familie bringen und mir
die sind voll mit fäkalien und um zu
seiner auswechslung
[Musik]
wie kommt man als junge zürcherin trug
sich mit fäkalien in lenos beschäftigen
es folgen jahre offen
es ist also für mich ist eben spannendes
thema ziehe was das bedeutet bemüht
waren sie eine mitschuld an und ich
glaube wc sich das thema offensichtlich
so wurde nicht dass das geklärt und um
sie sich eigentlich ganz spannendes
thema also ich glaub es ist ähnlich wie
solches thema will will soll betrifft
rund um das zu verbessern
jessica altenburg wurde vor 32 jahren in
die wohlhabende und unbeschwerte welt
der zürcher goldküste hinein geboren sie
studierte design lebte in london und new
york für einen edel hersteller entwarf
sie sündhaft teure möbel
sie hätte sich ein gemütliches leben
einrichten können
doch sie wollte mehr sie braucht er
etwas bewegen in der welt
in den slums der peruanischen hauptstadt
lima stranden zwei millionen menschen
auf der suche nach einem besseren leben
[Musik]
die hygienischen verhältnisse sind
katastrophal
die menschen verrichten ihr geschäft in
schäbigen lotterien wie diesen die
fäkalien verschicken unkontrolliert
zwischen den hütten ein gefährlicher
nährboden für krankheiten entsteht
wer krank ist kann nicht arbeiten
verdient kein geld und rutscht noch
tiefer in die wirtschaftliche not diesen
teufelskreis will jessica altenburger
unterbrechen
die unternehmerin begleitet ihre 15
angestellten regelmäßig zu den kunden
und die betriebsabläufe zu analysieren
[Applaus]
abholen
jessica altenburger unterhält sich mit
einer kundin amalia zwar rate hier in
der mitte bietet seit einem halben jahr
ein wc bei ihr
ich hatte früher auch eine latrine die
fühlt es sich immer schnell im sommer
wimmelte es von fliegen und stank
fürchterlich
das war für die nachbarn unangenehm und
natürlich auch für mich die ganze
umgebung war verdreckt
ich habe wirklich darunter gelitten ich
schütte kall konsument die die latrine
damit es nicht so stinkt es war einfach
filtern der toiletten service kostet 12
franken im monat
das ist viel geld bei einem
durchschnittseinkommen von rund 600
franken
trotzdem will jessica oldenburger kann
hilfswerk sein
sie bezahlen die kunden und das ist
eigentlich das macht kein sinn also das
ist nicht nachhaltig das ist eine
typische aufgabe bringt und was ganz
wichtig ist dass ab dem moment wo
prozent ist ein grund
konz
hat das bestimme und sarkastischen was
schlecht ist und da hat eigentlich habe
er oft seine waren das ein schlechtes
sind solisten oder hast du das abstellen
und es ist krieg zieht ja fürs fest ins
ganz wichtig dass die bringen renault
legt dagegen glaubt würde ja ich habe
das nur hier so genau aber doch es
bleibt das ist immer schwierig was da
passiert also sie störe und das ist weg
es ist umfeld kreiere wo man sich sicher
fühlt und würden sich super fühlen
[Musik]
im industriequartier am stadtrand von
lima befindet sich der werkhof der firma
hier werden die trockentoiletten
gewartet die altenburger von einem
schwedischen hersteller bezieht
ursprünglich wurden sie verkehren häuser
ohne kanalisation anschluss entwickelt
april auf dem rad kommen funktionen
es ist wichtig zu wissen dass sind
soweit ist und was mir da handlich wie
zwei heftige und wieder eröffnet
rené und bittet weiter öffne ich wofür
crowley elegant und das funktioniert so
das war einmal druck setzt dann öffnet
sich das unter ohne hat apple wurde ganz
afrika gesammelt
die wichtigste funktion ist die trennung
von urin und fäkalien der urin kann ohne
gesundheitliche bedenken in sickergruben
entsorgt werden
die eingesammelten fäkalien werden auf
dem firmengelände zu kompost verarbeitet
so ist ein sauberer und nachhaltiger
kreislauf möglich
oder sind der ehemalige ferrari das sind
die ehemalige fäkalien und das ist jetzt
eigentlich rapportierten überrascht also
es möglich dass man da noch überreste
von plastiksäcken kompostierbare
plastiksäcke und dass er mir dann so wie
bei und die interessante partie
jessica altenburger lanciert die ihre
witze geschäft zuerst in indien das
engagement endete in einem fiasko
die firma konnte nicht fuß fassen
getrieben von ihrer vision wagte sie
einen neustart in lima und es
funktionierte auftrieb sie auch das
geschafft
jetzt sportlich gab es
das ist einfach sinn macht das ist meine
idee ist immer mit einem los war hat ich
habe einerseits wohl auf christen
das kann funktionieren ich wüsste nicht
was ich will
sie bringen
und ich bleibe wisse das tut wirklich
gefällt und dass es einen unterschied im
lager macht das was braucht als
motivation
[Musik]
die
ja ich glaube
also es ist ein bewegen
das berührt einen immer und ich glaube
schwierig ist für mich nicht nur damals
viele sowie zwischen zwei welten
natürlich natürlich viel besser
[Gelächter]
es ist sonntagmorgen jessica altenburger
begleitet ihren wc monteur zu einer
neuen kunden
so will sie herausfinden wie sie das
angebot ihrer firma verbessern kann
[Musik]
ist das die gleiche stelle wo früher die
latrine war
nein nein die stand hinter dem haus
nelly palomino gomez zeigt wo sie früher
ihr geschäft verrichtete das erdloch
ihrer latrine im hinterhof hat sie
einfach zugeschüttet
das ist das große problem mit katherine
also einerseits ist natürlich das geht
einfach alles sah nach und und das nie
verarbeitet wird und dann scheint groß
und man hatte akkumulieren
krankheitserreger und sozialer insekten
anziehen und das ist das problem
und dann was da immer ganz zurück sie
ist das einfach der boote ich meistens
afghane gemacht wie sehr ihn also wird
dann oft geschwächt würde ganz
feuchtigkeit drin und zwar teilweise
zusammen brachen um ihn wirklich schon
als halbwüchsiger stürzt
dafür
der monteur passt ein spezielles
abluftrohr 1
es verhindert dass es in der stube
stinkt nelly palomino gomez lebt seit 16
jahren im slum als putzfrau verdient sie
200 franken die grösste eigentlich wäre
also wenn sie zahlt hat sie eigentlich
was sollen sie zu unseren preisen also
in meinem fall wie soll ich sagen ich
bin alleinstehend
darum ist es für mich schwierig jeden
monat zu zahlen
ich habe mir gesagt ich will kämpfen
damit das geld reicht und ich mir so ein
wc leisten kann
[Musik]
als erstes muss die neue kunden lernen
wir trocken wc funktioniert du stellst
den eimer mit ein wenig sägemehl so rein
dann kannst du den deckel zu machen
und wenn du dich hinsetzt geht unten die
klappe auf wichtig ist dass der urin
vorne runter läuft zum ersten mal in
ihrem leben ist nelly palomino gomez
stolze besitzerin eines witziges wie
immer vor deiner mannschaft die ganz
klare verantwortung also wie sichere
hygienische es ist deshalb weniger
insekten unten geht es aber aber die
zweite voranbringt bürger sind von denen
mancher und dann aber ist sehr wichtig
für sozialarbeit
also muss es natürlich als wc hat und
wann mal wieder mit dem multimedia
bietet sind ja ganz klar
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass das ist
schön
der aufkleber verkündet in diesem haus
lebt ein mensch mit einem modernen
sauberen witz
als firmengründerin kümmert sich jessica
altenburger um den bereich forschung und
entwicklung
in einem gemeinschaftsbüro trifft sie
sich mit ceo isabel medien
die deutsche hat peruanische wurzeln und
ist bestens vernetzt in der hauptstadt
jessica altenburger arbeitet die meiste
zeit von der schweiz aus
ihre geschäftspartnerin hat die
operative führung vor ort
die beiden lernten sich zufällig in
berlin kennen und merkten dass sie die
gleiche vision habe ich für mich also
mein ziel ist schon irgendwie auf ein
niveau zu kommen wo ich will nicht sagen
dass ganz lieber jetzt sagt wir
verwenden jetzt nur noch diese floss
aber dass das klima als stadt stolz ist
diese lösung groß gemacht zu haben weil
noch ist sie nicht so groß auf der welt
und ich möchte euch das ist groß werden
jessica altenburger baut mit ihren
angestellten ein muster wc für eine
werbeveranstaltung auf mit den bisher
rund 300 kunden funktioniert das
messegeschäft nur dank zusätzlichen
spendengeldern bis in vier jahren sollen
es 4000 kunden sei dann werde betrieb
selbst tragen
[Musik]
der mann mit der gelben karte ist marina
ordóñez er ist der chef dieses quartiers
in dem rund 550 menschen leben
er ist begeistert von der idee was
unternimmt die regierung um ihnen hier
im islam zu helfen nichts
wir bekommen keine unterstützung wir
machen alles mit eigenen händen
die straßen die treppen nur beim licht
hat die regierung geholfen
aber eigentlich müssen wir alles selber
machen auf die regierung außer beim
licht sonst noch nein
kommt er nie ein politiker hier vorbei
die politiker kommen immer nur während
des wahlkampfs und versprechen uns das
blaue vom himmel aber kaum sind sie
gewählt vergessen sie uns wieder so sind
sie die politiker weltweit besitzen mehr
menschen ein mobiltelefon als ein wc
zweieinhalb milliarden menschen haben
keinen zugang zu richtigen toiletten ein
riesiges potenzial für jessica
altenburgs geschäftsidee das ganze
system das funktioniert ein
flüchtlingslager anderes glauben sie
einander und dafür dass wir uns mit
anderen städten so dass wir uns mit
anderen organisationen wieder
zusammentun
auf dem papier mieten die kunden bei
jessica altenburger ein trocken wc was
sie bekommen ist weit mehr
sie holen sich jene würde in ihr leben
die für uns längst selbstverständlich
ist aufgabe von poker und was mich auch
zuletzt neun präventivmaßnahme
eigentlich und das ist alles was braucht
um ihre server komplett verantworten
[Musik]
[Applaus]